bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans ce savon garde ce soir
Nike plus fort que Macron et si les
marques racontaient mieux la France que
nos politiques c'est votre thèse Raphaël
Llorca bonsoir merci d'être là le roman
national des marques aux Éditions de
l'Aube un essai très stimulant sur la
manière dont les marques commerciales
façonnent nos imaginaires politiques
rôle que ne joue plus ceux qui nous
gouvernent on va en parler longuement
tout à l'heure dans la deuxième partie
notre grand débat ce soir qui a
abandonné le haut karabach c'est un
territoire qui se vide de ses habitants
jetés par milliers sur les routes de
l'exil plus de la moitié a déjà pris le
chemin de l'Arménie la fin d'une
république autoproclamée et de la
dislocation de l'URSS pouvaient-on
empêcher ce nettoyage ethnique nous en
débattons dans un instant avec mes
invités enfin nos affranchis ce soir
l'oeil sur l'actu du philosophe Nathan
devais le billet d'humeur de l'avocat
Bertrand Perrier et puis la nouvelle
chronique action planète de Léa Falco
voilà pour le menu ce soir on y va
Raphaël Orca c'est parti donc
dans notre débat et bien ce débat il
nous emmène en Arménie des dizaines de
milliers d'habitants qui cherchent à
fuir pour gagner l'Arménie on parle du
au carabar c'est une forme de tragédie
qui a lieu sous les yeux de la
communauté internationale au Karaba 10
jours après l'offensive de les
airbaïdjan le rêve d'indépendance de
cette petite enclave arménienne de 120
000 habitants c'est écroulé hier et
l'entité séparatiste s'est auto dissoute
qui met fin donc à 30 ans d'existence
bonsoir asmictal magihan merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes l'ambassadrice de l'Arménie en
France on a évidemment beaucoup de
questions à vous poser ce soir tout
comme à vous 6 mois qui arrive en
bonsoir ravi de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau vous êtes comédien metteur en
scène d'origine arménienne très engagée
vous avertez depuis longtemps sur la
cause arménienne et sur la défense du
haut carabar bonsoir Benjamin Haddad
bienvenue sur ce plateau député
renaissance de Paris membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'assemb nationale enfin bonsoir
torniquer Gordon bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes chercheur à Sciences
Po et vous êtes ancien ministre de
l'intégration européenne du gouvernement
de Michaël saccagéi Michael Chaka zizi
évidemment c'est là Georgie je sais que
c'est pas votre sujet évidemment mais
cette situation nous touche tous comme
citoyens donc n'hésitez pas à Raphaël
rocade voilà interrogez nos invités
quand vous le souhaitez on va commencer
par rembobiner un peu le fil le fil de
ces derniers jours remettre ce conflit
qui dure depuis des années maintenant
dans son contexte car elle appuie grâce
à Stéphane blackovski qu'on accueille
tout de suite
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
mon cher Stéphane bonsoir à vous je vous
invite à faire la bonne chose bonsoir à
toutes et tous alors je suis désolé mais
pour commencer cette émission je vais
vous montrer une carte qui n'est plus
tout à fait valable l'idée c'était de
montrer l'isolement de l'enclave
arménienne du okaraba dans le territoire
de l'Azerbaïdjan sauf que aujourd'hui
l'eau caravane n'existe plus puisque
c'est dirigeants viennent d'annoncer sa
dissolution mais on va rester un peu sur
cette carte pour rappeler quelques
étapes de l'histoire d'abord dire que
les Arméniens sont présents dans le haut
Karaba depuis des millénaires mais
l'histoire moderne elle commence en 1923
au moment de l'occupation soviétique de
la région quand Staline décide que l'eau
Caraba arménien va passer sous contrôle
de ce qu'on appelle à l'époque la
République socialiste d'azerbage alors
bien sûr la décision n'a jamais été
acceptée si bien que en 91 lorsque
l'URSS se disloque et bien le ok rabat
prononce son indépendance donc une
indépendance qui n'est reconnue par
personne par aucun pays de l'ONU même
pas par l'Arménie n'empêche une guerre
se déclare en 94 qui permet
à l'Arménie de prendre le contrôle vous
voyez le 15% en gros du territoire de
l'Azerbaïdjan c'est une guerre très dure
il y a eu 30 000 morts et surtout des
centaines de milliers d'azériques qui
ont dû fuir la zone pour
se replier en Naser belge en sauf que
évidemment laser les gens voulaient
prendre sa revanche ce qui est arrivé en
2020 d'abord en reprenant le contrôle du
territoire et puis aujourd'hui on a
cette situation où laser des gens a
réussi à rayer pour de bons le haut
carabar de la carte donc forcément
l'Arménie ce sont d'autant plus de
menacés que elle ne peut même plus
compter sur son principal allié qui
était jusque là la Russie vous voyez en
2021 après sa défaite contre les
arbaïdjan l'Arménie avait appelé la
Russie à l'aider contre une éventuelle
nouvelle attaque bon Poutine étant
engagée dans l'invasion de l'Ukraine il
avait sans doute d'autres soucis si bien
que aujourd'hui donc l'Arménie se
détourne de la Russie cherchent plutôt
une alliance une protection américaine
faut dire que l'armée il y a d'autant
plus de raison de se sentir menacé que
de leur côté laserbaïdjan
un allié très solide en l'occurrence la
Turquie la Turquie qui je le rappelle a
mené un génocide en 1915 contre les
Arméniens donc aujourd'hui lorsque
erdouan se félicite de la victoire de
l'Azerbaïdjan en disant que ça ouvre de
nouvelles opportunités ça paraît des
propos très menaissants pour les
Arméniens et qui s'inquiète notamment à
l'idée que azerbaïdjanais et azeri et
turc puissent se mettre d'accord pour en
fait envahir la chute de l'Arménie et
créer un continuité territoriale entre
la Turquie et le laser beigean donc dans
ce contexte il y a une question qui se
pose bien sûr c'est que on a beaucoup
aidé vous le savez l'Union européenne
l'Ukraine mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
lorsqu'il s'agit d'aider et bien pas
grand chose donc l'explication elle est
assez simple c'est que pour faire face à
la perte du gaz russe et bien l'an
dernier il receveur Layenne a été en
israélienne des contrats de livraison de
gaz 15 milliards de gaz a été livré à
l'Union européenne donc forcément c'est
un peu se fâcher avec laser bedjan il y
a cependant des voix qui s'élèvent en
Europe notamment des voix françaises je
vais vous propose d'écouter Nathalie
Loiseau qui est une ancienne ministre de
l'Europe sous le gouvernement Édouard
Philippe et qui est maintenant député
rignaux au Parlement l'écoute
aujourd'hui les bombes pleuvent sur le
haut-karaba mais Bakou encourage les
civils Arméniens du territoire à partir
vers l'Arménie cela a un nom cela
s'appelle un nettoyage ethnique par
notre faiblesse et par notre passivité
nous en sommes devenus les complices
alors ces propos sont très sévères je
suis sûr que nombreux sont ceux qui
partagent cette indignation mais
évidemment la question aujourd'hui c'est
que faire pour aider l'Arménie madame
l'ambassadrice merci beaucoup merci
Stéphane ce mot là vous l'entendez il
n'est pas prononcé que par les Arméniens
c'est une député européenne le mot de
nettoyage ethnique vous vous dites enfin
c'est déjà ça de reconnaître la réalité
de ce qui est en train de se passer
je crois qu'il est très important de
mettre des mots à ce qui se passe et
Nathalie Loiseau qui est un député
européenne aujourd'hui mais comme vous
aviez rappelé a été aussi un ministre
chargé des affaires européennes le dit
en comprenant tout le contexte et en
comprenant parfaitement le crime qui se
passe actuellement on peut pas qualifier
autrement que nettoyage ethnique
l'épuration ethnique le drame absolu qui
se passe en temps réel presque mise en
ligne sonieux j'ai entendu le mot de
génocide je crois que vous l'avez repris
en vous en vous fondant sur certains
rapports il y a des il y a des crimes de
guerre il y a des exactions qui se
produisent au-delà des de l'exil forcé
et la famine qui menace
la population arménienne aujourd'hui du
haut-karaba ne viennent pas en Arménie
par loisirs ni fuient les misères ils
viennent en Arménie parce qu'il fuient
un génocide parce qu'il fut la menace de
génocide et sont pas les Arméniens mais
c'est les spécialistes en matière de
génocide des historiens notables avec
une notoriété reconnue en cette matière
qui alerte depuis des mois sur le risque
de génocide notamment le premier
procureur de la Cour in pénale
internationale monsieur Louise Moreno
aucun pot parlait déjà d'un génocide en
cours dans un rapport très détaillé de
28 pages qu'il avait publié il y a plus
d'un mois un autre spécialiste le
premier conseiller du Secrétaire général
des Nations Unies pour la prévention de
génocide donc encore une fois ayant
toute
l'expertise et la connaissance du sujet
parler aussi de génocide en cours et je
pense que ce mot est d'autant plus
grave parce que il s'agit d'un peuple
qui a subi déjà un génocide dans son
passé récent et aujourd'hui la question
qui se pose pour l'ensemble des
Arméniens est-ce que un siècle après le
crime de 1915 est-ce que une fois de
plus les Arméniens sont menacés
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie
qui est menacée on va y venir depuis le
11 juillet la voie de passage c'est un
petit couloir très étroit entre
l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Arménie ce fameux
corridor a été bloqué par l'Azerbaïdjan
maintenant que la République a été dû au
Caraba autodissoute est-ce que ce blocus
était toujours en vigueur est-ce que la
pénurie de médicaments la fin c'est
toujours la réalité il y a très peu de
journalistes sur place on ne sait pas
trop ce qui s'y passe
la gerbaïdjan a bloqué ludique croûte
qui reliait le haut carabar à l'Arménie
et donc au reste du monde le 12 décembre
2022 donc ça fait presque dix mois que
le corridor est entièrement est bloqué
il y avait quelques passages occasionnel
de la Croix-Rouge pour apporter un peu
de médicaments et un peu dans les
maternisé depuis le mois de juin le
blocus était devenu total complet parce
que même les voitures de la Croix-Rouge
n'arrivaient plus à rien apporter et la
famille n'a s'installer et la situation
était déjà extrêmement grave et c'est
pour ça aussi les spécialistes par les
déjà d'un génocide en cours en
s'appuyant sur la Convention
internationale sur la prévention et la
répression du prime de génocide parce
que il y avait des laserbaïdjan
délibérément créer des conditions de vie
insupportable pour que les gens puissent
partir pour bien comprendre il faut
absolument pas prendre au pied de la
lettre que dit le président Algérie
encore aujourd'hui rester on préservera
vos droits politiques et culturels et
religieux vous vous dites aujourd'hui
aux Arméniens du haut-karaba revenez
partez au plus vite c'est ça
non je dirais si une action de forte
internationale pour être déclenchée pour
arrêter ce qui se passe pour arrêter ce
nettoyage ethnique pour des garanties de
sécurité à cette population c'est ça que
l'Arménie attend on va y venir à
l'Europe à la France ils m'ont carrément
vous ça fait longtemps que vous alerter
j'ai relu il y avait en août une de vos
tribunes dans le Figaro comment vous
vivez ce qui se passe depuis cette
offensive qui a commencé il y a dix
jours dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
c'est de la colère c'est de la
résignation non pas de la résignation
non non
descendant de l'Anatolie et les mêmes
les mêmes mécanismes qui ont été mis en
place en 1900 déjà 14 15 16
17 a duré longtemps
nous le connaissons je suis de la
troisième génération certains d'entre
nous vivent au Liban d'autres en Syrie
d'autres en Jordanie d'autres en Irak
d'autres à Los Angeles d'autres à
Marseille d'autres en Grèce etc nous
sommes tous ces descendants et c'est les
mêmes mécanismes c'est-à-dire à l'époque
les jeunes turcs quand ils mettent en
place le génocide des Arméniens n'est
pas seulement par la suite des Grecs et
des
acérocaldéens dire que d'arriver à faire
une une Turquie entre guillemets pure
libre de toute entité qu'ils auraient
précédés qui seraient non turc reste les
Kurdes ils sont pas mal plus de millions
que nous donc on va voir comment ils
vont entre parenthèses régler cette
histoire mais le mécanisme est le même
c'est-à-dire de mettre en place toute
une toute une chose qui un appareil
génocidaire et pendant qu'on le fait
dans d'essayer d'en effacer les traces
c'est ce qui est en train de faire
monsieur Alif évidemment bien conseillé
par Monsieur le Président de l'azerbage
et bien conseillé par Monsieur adogan et
aussi bien
fort du silence et de l'impunité de la
Turquie qui perdure donc qui se disent
je vais continuer pas seulement sur les
Arméniens mais aussi sur les Kurdes
comme on le voit comme ils bombarde des
Kurdes dans le nord de l'Irak
géopolitiques et aux pays frontaliers
c'est compliqué à la fois parce que les
religions sont différentes parce que
effectivement la puissance turque vous
vous sentez abandonné ou pas encore une
fois l'Arménie est trop seule
ça commence à être une habitude donc on
a on a un petit peu
cette chose de pouvoir compter sur
nous-mêmes mais aussi on a cette
manifesté de se dire tiens il y a un
gouvernement arménien il est ce qu'il
est il a essayé de se tourner vers
l'Occident de démocratie et naïvement ce
gouvernement s'est dit peut-être que va
m'aider l'Occident on l'a vu en Géorgie
comment ça s'est passé on en parlera
mieux que moi je suppose mais non ça
c'est oui il y a une espèce de d'abandon
et mais je pense qu'il y a d'un autre
côté aussi le fait de vouloir embrasser
la démocratie pas seulement pour plaire
aux démocrates c'est parce qu'aussi à
l'Occident mais c'est parce qu'aussi on
y croit on a envie de sortir de ce
système
féodal qui
enfin de cette région de Russie et de
parler aussi de la Russie certains
parlent même de trahison de Moscou je
voudrais quand même qu'on les entendent
les Arméniens je vous donne la parole
juste après ces Arméniens du haut
karabach qui prennent la fuite du jour
au lendemain et puis du côté de la rue
aussi à Erevan la capitale de l'Arménie
on accepte très mal cette capitulation
c'est un reportage avec les équipes de
l'AFP sing et Baptiste garguichartier
10 jours après l'offensive éclair menée
par l'Azerbaïdjan il continue d'influer
par milliers l'exode de 65000 Arméniens
en provenance du haut-karaba ici des
kilomètres d'embouteillages d'une
population qui a tout abandonné
tout le monde en est conscient on a
perdu notre passé parce qu'on n'a rien
emporté avec nous on a tout laissé
derrière nous
je ne sais pas où je vais aller je me
dirige vers Goris maintenant si nous
mettent dans un hôtel j'y resterai sinon
je dormirai dans la voiture
pour les Arméniens pas question de
rester sous le contrôle de l'Azerbaïdjan
le Premier ministre arménien dénonce une
épuration ethnique
mais Bakou elle réfute ses accusations
dans ses rues la population se réjouit
du triomphe
nous sommes en train de libérer notre
propre pays nous ne menons pas à une
opération dans un pays étranger nous le
faisons sur nos propres terres
il quitte le pays il part d'eux-mêmes on
les oblige pas à partir s'ils respectent
les lois et la Constitution alors ils
peuvent rester
mes aérévans cette semaine la débâcles
fait l'effet d'un coup de massue
certains Arméniens réclament même la
démission de leur chef d'État
on demande la démission du capitulateur
aucun chef d'État qui s'est rendu n'a le
droit de diriger le pays
on subit des pertes croissantes aussi
bien dans le haut-karaba qu'en Arménie
l'objectif c'est d'appeler notre peuple
à s'unir et à éliminer ce gouvernement
antinational
alors que la république séparatiste
autoproclamée à annoncé sa dissolution
le rêve de ces réfugiés pour retrouver
leur maison semble définitivement
enterré
c'est très compliqué de comprendre ce
qui se passe parce qu'il y a peu
d'informations qui remontent la
capitulation est claire on s'était David
contre Goliath évidemment
l'armée arménienne était trop faible
mais comment comprendre que cette
république est décidée
[Musique]
devant les armes d'une supériorité à la
fois économique démographique militaire
qui s'est en plus agrandi ces dernières
années parce que si on a parlé dans le
dans la présentation de votre
chroniqueur dans les années 90 l'Arménie
a gagné cette guerre un peu aussi à
l'aide de la Russie a gagné clairement
les azeries sont reculés ils ont reculé
ils ont abandonné leur territoire aussi
en dehors du carambar et 20 ans ou 30
ans plus tard ils ont eu leur revanche
d'abord en 2020 où ils ont pratiquement
récupéré
tous les territoires qui étaient autour
du carambar et en plus une partie du
haut Karaba mais aujourd'hui les Russes
il y avait des soldats
de la guerre en Ukraine la Russie n'a
pas voulu non plus défendre son alliée
arménien et notamment l'actuel dirigeant
Nicolas pachinian qui considère pas
comme étant très proche ou très loyal de
la Russie pourquoi parce que Nicole
pachinian a essayé depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir il essayait d'un petit peu
diversifier sa politique étrangère de ne
pas dépendre aussi fortement de la
Russie le désir de démocratie
également parce qu'il est arrivé au
pouvoir suite à quelque chose qui
ressemble à une révolution de couleur
que les Russes détestent enfin l'actuel
régime à Moscou déteste et mais par
contre je trouve les gens certaines
personnes qui demandent sa démission ou
elles sont son départ un petit peu
injustes parce que ce n'est pas
uniquement la faute c'est jeudi mon
opinion à l'école pachinian d'avoir
perdu cette guerre pendant 25 ans les
gouvernements précédents ont fait une
confiance aveugle à la Russie et c'est
un peu le résultat de cette confiance
aveugle cette domination cette politique
étrangère à vecteur unique que l'Arménie
paye maintenant je viens vers vous mais
sur cette rue qui veut la démission du
Premier ministre alors on n'est pas en
mesure de voir à l'ampleur de de cette
colère mais qu'est-ce que vous dites
comment vous réagissez le peuple
arménien est extrêmement inquiet qu'ils
sont en harmonie que dans la diaspora
c'est ce sentiment d'impuissance face à
une épuration ethnique face à un drame
inévitable
c'est compréhensible après vous-même
vous avez dit à juste titre c'est David
contre Goliath donc le rapport de force
était tellement inégal 120 000 Arméniens
au carabar affamés depuis 10 mois et en
contrepartie
l'Azerbaïdjan et le chroniqueur l'a
rappelé aussi avec un soutien très fort
de la Turquie qui menaçait d'achever le
travail de 1915 et qui après la victoire
de l'Azerbaïdjan à bas coût le président
turc monsieur egdogan
disait que l'homme de inverse Pacha
serait ce jour-là illuminé et verpacha
sachant qu'il faisait partie d'être
inaugira de jointure qui avait
commandité le génocide arménien donc je
pense que certains spécialistes parlent
d'un génocide long qui a commencé dès la
fin de 20e de 19e siècle par les
massacres dans l'Empire ottoman de 1815
1896 et qui sont qui avec quelques
interruptions sont arrivés jusqu'en
maintenant trahison de la Russie vous
diriez madame l'ambassadrice ce mot est
trop fort ou pas parce que là il y avait
quand même malgré tout malgré le conflit
ukrainien la possibilité de réagir vous
savez il y a 2000 soldats russes comme
il a été rappelé qui était dans le
garaba et c'était en termes de l'accord
de cessez-le-feu qui avait été signé le
9 novembre 2020 suite à la guerre de 44
jours donc en 2020 et ces soldats russes
étaient censés d'assurer la sécurité de
la population et duo Karaba aujourd'hui
s'il y a aucun arménien qui reste dans
le garaba et plus de 4
3/4 de la population a déjà fui le
regard Rabat et demain ou après-demain
il y aura plus aucun arménien qui reste
on peut pas dire que les Russes ont
accompli leur mission
et que fait la France et que fait
l'Europe Benjamin Haddad mais là les
Arméniens se sont abandonnés abandonnés
par l'Europe la France apporté la voix
du soutien à l'Arménie vous savez
parfois bien seul en Europe on a
augmenté la économie que la duanitaire
passer de 5 à 12 millions d'euros dans
les derniers jours la voie de la France
porte au Conseil de sécurité des Nations
unies aussi pour apporter une assistante
envoyer des soutien c'est quoi mais mais
ce qui est évident c'est que aujourd'hui
l'Europe a pas été à la hauteur c'est un
échec pour l'Europe pour soutenir
l'harmonie vous l'avez vous mais
accueillir des réfugiés est-ce que c'est
un soutien militaire qu'est-ce que c'est
il y a plusieurs éléments mais déjà vous
vous l'avez montré dans votre reportage
la présidente vanderline en
désherbaïdjan pour acheter du gaz
aujourd'hui on estime que le gaz qui est
importé d'Azerbaïdjan est plus important
que les capacités de production
d'Azerbaïdjan donc en fait beaucoup
soupçonnent c'est le cas par exemple de
Nathalie Loiseau au Parlement européen
que la Russie
aussi la abat-jour aujourd'hui pour
contourner les sanctions qui ont liées à
la guerre contre l'Ukraine vous avez
d'un côté le président Charles Michel
qui veut faire des diplomaties l'autre
côté la présidente vandalayen qui vient
signer un accord sur sur le gaz on n'a
jamais été capable d'assumer un rapport
de force avec les airbagans donc si on
veut si on veut peser
la crise énergétique et les sanctions
sur le gaz russe qui en Europe parce que
nous on n'apporte pas de gaz
d'Azerbaïdjan mais on a un salon de
partenaire l'Italie l'Autriche ou la
Hongrie dans c'est le cas et puis je
dirais même au-delà de ça l'Europe n'est
pas capable d'assumer un rapport de
force si elle veut peser sur le conflit
si elle veut capable de soutenir les
Arméniens et d'avoir ça sa voix dans
dans cette situation bien il faut il
faut peser il faut assumer un rapport de
force je vous donne un exemple très
précis sur la question de l'aide
militaire on a un outil qu'on utilise
pour aider les Ukrainiens qui s'appelle
à facilité européenne de paix c'est à
dire c'est un fond que les pays qui
livrent des armes à l'U utilise pour se
refinancer et bien l'Union européenne a
refusé que
bien entre je pense la question du gaz
et le fait qu'il y a une forme de
naïveté à considérer qu'on risque de
s'aligner à lièvre alors si on veut
continuer à parler à jouer un rôle
diplomatique
livre des armes il faut qu'on assume ce
rapport de force vous allez voir c'est
intéressant je voudrais quand même le
Sunny parce que vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la Russie et c'est
fondamental parce que le premier spa
chignon le dit lui-même ils ont été
abandonnés et trahis par la Russie parce
que la Russie a des troupes qui sont
censés être des observateurs de maintien
de la paix depuis 2020 qui ont détourné
le regard on ne peut pas imaginer que
l'Azerbaïdjan aurait lancé cette
opération sans avoir le feu vert de la
Russie parce qu'au-delà de la question
territoriale il y a une dimension
politique et idéologique il veut se
débarrasser de ce régime de pachinian
qui aujourd'hui
faisant démocratie veut lutter contre la
corruption aujourd'hui ou hier les
dirigeants russes condamnés la volonté
par de rejoindre par exemple le Statut
de Rome c'est-à-dire la Cour pénale
internationale le droit international
alors c'est rare d'entendre c'est aussi
ça un député dire l'Europe a échoué vous
êtes d'accord avec Yannick Jadot qui est
fraîchement élu au Sénat l'écologie
historique le fait que l'Azerbaïdjan
produit et nous exporte en Europe du gaz
fait que nous laissons ce pays sans
sanction et qu'on arrête de considérer
que les Arméniens sont le prix à payer
de de notre addiction au gaz il y a
quelques jours encore le président de
Total le PDG de Total Patrick pouyanet
était avec le président Alif alors que
s'organiser l'épuration ethnique des
Arméniens
c'est ce qu'on appelle la Real politique
une fois de plus sur le dos de l'Arménie
non parce que je pense pas seulement sur
le dos de l'Arménie si vous permettez
parce que je pense que sur le c'est sur
le dos de l'éthique même de l'Europe de
de cela faillite si vous voulez éthique
politique morale de l'Europe c'est ça la
faille c'est à dire que bien sûr nous
qui sommes au premier chef les victimes
de de cette de cette abandon mais c'est
pas seulement une trahison envers envers
le Russe aurait travaillé l'arménien ou
la France aurait trahi non c'est d'abord
une trahison envers elle-même
envers ces valeurs envers envers ce qui
nous constitue envers sa verticalité
envers même s'inspiritualité à même la
politique elle essaie de construire même
son utopie qui a laissé de construire
ces données de la force aux ennemis de
la démocratie c'est donner de la force
au type comme à l'IFI qui qui se dit
tiens je vais sortir un bifton je vais
le mettre sur la table excuse-moi d'être
vulgaire mais aussi simple que ça madame
vandereyen ce qu'elle fait elle
contrevient elle-même elle contrevient
elle-même à l'embargo qu'elle a qu'elle
a imposé de toutes ses forces et tous
ses vœux contre Poutine elle a très bien
fait
en allant voir à l'if qui comme vous le
dit probablement secrète polichinelle
que le parce que c'est c'est presque un
île de voyou qu'ils ont fait entre donc
le gaz qui passe par Bakou en allant le
chercher elle contrevient elle-même et
un jour on le saura elle sera elle punie
sera-t-elle inquiétée sera telle
questionnée là-dessus devra t-elle
répondre de ça je le souhaite pas pour
la punir personnellement parce que je me
fiche complètement de sa personne mais
parce que en faisant ce qu'elle fait
elle abîme elle abîme notre notre
stabilité morale elle abîme ça
il faudra que l'Europe rentre des
comptes c'est un peu ce que vous dites
carrément les valeurs de l'Europe sont
piétinées et on pourra peut-être plus
regarder en face clairement les valeurs
et les intérêts
mais la stabilité politique le fait de
lutter contre les conflits le fait de ne
pas laisser notre voisinage être partagé
par des pays autoritaires comme la
Turquie et la Russie l'une des leçons du
24 février 2022 de la guerre d'agression
contre l'Ukraine c'est que on peut pas
détourner le regard quand on a des
tensions géopolitiques dans les Balkans
en Europe de l'Est dans le Caucase qu'il
faut que l'Europe s'implique en une
élection américaine l'an prochain avec
peut-être Donald Trump qui sera réélu
président qui voit une fois de plus nos
tourner le dos et essayer de nous
diviser il faut qu'on soit capable de
s'assumer il faut qu'on soit capable si
on veut peser et comment comment vous
expliquer comment ne fasse pas assez
c'est quoi et bien la naïveté la peur la
division il y a parfois des intérêts
économiques de court terme de court
terme qui prennent le dessus sur à mon
avis une vision géopolitique plus
réaliste et puis il y a une forme de de
naïveté mais c'est vrai que l'Europe
tarde encore alors à se réveiller alors
on le fait avec
le plus en Europe non mais vous savez
sur la question par exemple du du gaz on
avait dit pendant des années que jamais
on ne pourrait se passer du gaz et du
pétrole de la Russie et pourtant nous
avons réussi en moins d'un an à le faire
et aujourd'hui on accepte de se placer
dans un même rapport de dépendance avec
un autre pays c'est pas sérieux c'est
aussi une question de souveraineté pour
nous torniquer quels sont les pays au
fond qui sont des les plus les moins
allant on va dire ça comme ça
les pays de l'Europe centrale ou
l'Europe de méridionale mais je voulais
parler de d'autres choses également par
exemple quand ça l'Ukraine en Europe a
mis 20 ans 25 ans avant de condamner le
régime russe d'imposer les sanctions
donc on est très lent donc c'est très
très difficile deuxième chose l'Europe
peut encore faire des choses pour pour
l'Arménie
malheureusement pour le caramar à mon
avis ça va être très difficile de faire
quoi que ce soit en plus il y a le droit
international qui dit que les azéries
peuvent dire c'est notre territoire
souverains vous pouvez faire grand-chose
mais on peut faire des choses pour
l'Arménie premièrement on peut commencer
à parler de une perspective européenne
pour ce pays qui est maintenant cherche
en plus à diversifier ses politiques
étrangère et de dépendre beaucoup moins
de la Russie à la porte au négociations
dans négociation
d'abord premier pas ça serait de
reconnaître l'Arménie un avenir européen
déjà première chose et après c'est les
étapes suivantes après c'était
éventuellement reconnaître le statut de
candidat etc ça prendra du temps plus il
faut pas faire peur non plus à
l'électeur lambda en France ou encore un
pays qui va qui va rejoindre l'Union ça
prendra du temps mais sur le plan des
principes c'est très important et ça va
en plus aider l'actuel le gouvernement
arménien qui est démocratique qui est
pro-occidentale de de vendre quelque
chose à sa population parce que là on
voit qu'il est quand même extrêmement
chahuté il y a le narratif russe qui dit
c'est ils ont perdu des territoires
parce qu'ils ont voulu être un
pro-occidentaux et démocratique donc il
faut il faut il faut casser ce narratif
en leur proposant quelque chose et
deuxième chose aussi des choses très
concrète c'est plus facile à faire
peut-être c'est qu'aujourd'hui il existe
une mission d'observation à la frontière
entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan entre
les frontières souverains de souverain
de l'Arménie l'Azerbaïdjan et c'est une
mission européenne il y a juste quelques
dizaines de personnes on peut renforcer
cette mission rajouter d'autres
observateurs pour empêcher que cette
guerre continue ensuite sur le
territoire arménien strictosensus
de Monsieur goriazet si même on
considérait le haut carabar qu'on
faisait un parti au terme du droit
international de l'intérêt territoriale
de l'Azerbaïdjan ça ne justifie pas la
violation par de leurs herbaïdjan de
semaine ou international parce que le
droit international ne se résume pas
qu'aux principes de l'intérité
territoriale de l'azerbation parce que
l'Azerbaïdjan aujourd'hui violent
l'intérêt des territoriale de l'Arménie
continue à le faire il y a presque 200
km² du territoire souverain arménien qui
sont sur le contrôle ce sont occupés par
l'Azerbaïdjan premièrement après quand
Saddam Hussein gazifié sa propre
population parce que les Kurdes qui
étaient gazifiées étaient en Irak ça ne
justifiait pas l'action de Saddam
Hussein juste parce que cette population
faisait partie de l'Irak donc je pense
que quand on peut pas dire qu'on ne peut
rien faire dans le Carambar on ne
pourrait rien faire dans le Caraba parce
que c'était au sein de l'intérêt
territoire on sent que la menace
aujourd'hui elle va voilà elle va
continuer à peser fort et on verra ce
que l'Europe fait la Turquie pour vous
avec l'Azerbaïdjan son but c'est quoi
c'est d'anéantir l'Arménie je vais
reprendre les mots qui sont à prononcer
par les Turcs et les Algérie depuis des
années ils disent ce sont les deux états
de la même nation et il est vrai il ne
sait pas faux parce qu'il y a une très
forte proximité
[Musique]
la France elle a jamais eu peur de faire
le rapport de force avec Monsieur
erdegan Emmanuel Macron avait envoyé un
navire en Méditerranée orientale pour
défendre la souveraineté maritime de la
Grèce et Achille quand elle était
menacées par la Turquie il a eu des
propos très durs aussi lorsque la
Turquie avait envahi le nord-est syrien
aujourd'hui on porte aussi cette
question de la défense de l'Arménie au
niveau européen et international et
d'ailleurs j'aurais quand même dire que
certains de nos partenaires commencent à
nous rejoindre on a entendu des propos
très forts aussi de la ministre aux
infrastrogers
de sécurité qui a demandé l'envoi
d'observateurs internationaux c'est sous
l'impulsion de la France qu'on a vu
cette mission d'en parler torniquer de
l'Union européenne de d'observation à la
frontière entre l'armée d'Azerbaïdjan je
crois qu'effectivement la question du
soutien à l'intégrité territoriale de
l'harmonie absolument fondamentale ça
passera par des partenariats économiques
en français ça appartenait passera par
je pense aussi par un soutien militaire
on a rehaussé la coopération de défense
à l'ambassade de France à
Erevan je crois qu'on peut le faire
aussi au niveau je tenais l'exemple de
la facilité européenne de paix et en
effet accompagner l'Arménie dans un
processus européen reconnaissant d'abord
ça sa perspective européenne aujourd'hui
les Arméniens veulent être une
démocratie tournée vers l'Europe tourner
vers l'Occident qui lutte contre la
corruption il y a aujourd'hui des
ingérences il y a de la désinformations
qui viennent de Russie qui alimentent
aussi les mouvements que l'on voit dans
la rue donc je crois que là on a aussi
un devoir de continuer à soutenir les
Arméniens qui veulent se tourner vers
nous je vais vous donner le mot de la
fin peut-être vous voudriez réagir c'est
vrai que cette offensive elle était
prévisible je crois que tout le monde
l'a compris au terme de ce débat et on
se dit quand même quel de poids de
mesure avec le crâne malgré tout même si
évidemment le peuple craien souffre et
c'est totalement injuste mais là on a
l'impression d'une forme de guerre
éclair
alors j'observe tout ça avec évidemment
beaucoup de gravité on sent sur ce
plateau avec beaucoup d'humilité parce
que c'est très au-delà de mes de ma zone
mais si vous avez une question à poser
mais il se trouve que j'ai plutôt une
anecdote à vous partager parce qu'il se
trouve j'étais irrévan cet été mon ami
très proche s'est marié là-bas avec une
arménienne et j'ai été frappé par
la place particulière qui occupée la
France là-bas évidemment et une scène
qui m'a bouleversé un chauffeur de taxi
à Evan qui se rend compte que nous
sommes français dans sa voiture ah vous
venez de la France on vous aime beaucoup
mais je vous en prie nous sommes un pays
en guerre venez nous aider et il y avait
une forme d'impuissance évidemment de
notre part mais voilà qui a un
témoignage assez assez poignant de à la
plat à la fois la place particulière que
je joue la France et en même temps ce
cri et ce cri se cri du coeur si moi je
vais vous laisser terminer qu'est-ce que
vous attendez précisément aujourd'hui
j'attends rien de particulier et
j'attends que les choses se passent dans
l'action et dans l'honnêteté et dans je
dirais même un mot qui semble des yeux
et dans l'honneur j'attends ça c'est
tout quand vous parlez ce que va arriver
aux Arméniens est-ce que les Turcs vont
le faire vous demanderez vous poser la
question de n'importe quel arménien du
monde ou qu'il soit ou qu'elle soit en
Europe ou en moyenne environ en Arménie
il vous et elle vous dira la même chose
ils veulent non seulement c'est pas
seulement une guerre de conquête mais ce
sera une guerre d'éradication un
génocide c'est-à-dire que nous sommes
les Arméniens les témoins gênants de
leur narratif à eux en tant que
civilisation en tant que en tant que
pays qui se fonde sur quelque chose en
fait qu'il faut il y a une schizophrénie
historique en Turquie qui consiste à
dire ça c'est nous ça c'est nous ça
dedans à vous vous êtes arrivés au 10e
siècle
vous faites bien là on s'arrête là merci
à vous d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous
allez rester avec moi Raphaël Lorca dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis ce soir Nathan de
verre va s'interroger sur l'autonomie le
fameux mot magique du Président hier
laché au corps le regard de Bertrand
Perrier sur les coulisses de l'élection
de l'écrivain amine malouf nouveau
Secrétaire perpétuel à l'Académie
française et puis dans l'action planète
Léa Falco de quoi nous parlez-vous ce
soir un sujet pas très sexy mais
important les analyses socio-économiques
des grands projets d'infrastructure on
va parler autoroute je pense merci à
tout à l'heure mais d'abord on plonge
dans le roman national des marques votre
livre est sorti il y a 15 jours je peux
vous dire que dans les déjeuners
politiques on en parle énormément il
crée un débat dans la classe politique
les marques plus fortes que nos
dirigeants pour raconter la France ce
que nous sommes ce qui nous rassemble
comment en est-on arrivé là c'est dans
l'invitation d'Hélène Bonduelle et on en
parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite rappelle Llorca c'est
parce que vous vous demandez qui raconte
la France aujourd'hui
quiconque notre roman national ce récit
qu'une nation fait d'elle-même et votre
constat est implacable ce ne sont plus
les politiques mais les marques et c'est
juste communiquant Raphaël Llorca vous
codirigez l’observatoire Marc imaginaire
de consommation et politique dans votre
dernier ouvrage vous analysez la façon
dont les marques ont remplacé les
politiques pour susciter l'adhésion
raconter le collectif comme cette pub
Nike de 2011 la marque et le nouveau
sponsor de l'équipe de France de foot
sur une tirade de Cyrano de Bergerac à
travers cette équipe elle raconte la
France toute entière
je carte du pied jescarmouche je coupe
je frotte il a donc à la fin de l'envoi
je touche
on touche au plus près de ce qui
constitue le récitational c'est-à-dire à
la fois quelque chose qui appartient à
une tradition ancienne littéraire c'est
quand même la France pays de des lettres
et des grands textes mais adapté à des
formes de nouveaux poèmes quoi qui sont
aujourd'hui les rappeurs et surtout avec
cette incarnation d'une France
aujourd'hui multiculturelle et le
paradoxe c'est que soit une marque
étrangère comme Nike qui produit ce
récit national vous vous appuyez sur
cette étude de décembre dernier à la
question qui raconte le mieux la France
aujourd'hui un tiers des personnes
interrogées répondent personne pire le
politique arrive en huitième position
pas étonnant alors que les marques
s'engouffrent dans ce vide pour raconter
la France plurienne
on est avant-gardiste on n'est pas
coincé on a un humour hors pair on n'est
pas de mauvaise foi on est juste un peu
paradoxal les marques avancent là où les
politiques ne savent plus faire on n'est
pas carré
on est hexagonal
pourtant selon vous il y a un con qui
l'a bien compris le rassemblement
national qui s'est riche comme le parti
du pouvoir d'achat épuise dans les
pratiques de la grande distribution ce
que je crains c'est que elle maîtrise
cette langue de la consommation examen
façon qu'on a abandonné à l'extrême
droite beaucoup de thématiques la
laïcité la nation le drapeau la fierté
des Français ne lui laissant pas le
consommateur voilà donc c'est un peu un
appel aux forces de gauche alors face à
cette avalanche d'image et de pubs qui a
envahi la politique nous avons une
question Raphaël Llorca comment
concrètement ce qui nous gouverne
peuvent reprendre la plume de ce roman
national
réponse rafaleur k bon est-ce que tout
n'est pas perdu
évidemment ce que j'ai voulu faire dans
ce livre c'est effectivement essayer
d'éclairer de manière transverse le
politique on s'intéressant non plus à
son discours produit ce que j'ai fait
dans les deux précédents livres mais on
s'intéressant à des acteurs qui a priori
n'ont rien à voir avec tout ça mais qui
sont les marques commerciales
effectivement la thèse est parfaitement
démontrée dans ce sujet c'est que les
acteurs marchand profitent du vide
laissez pas le politique pour proposer
leur propre récit national bon
peut-être déjà pour ceux qui nous
regardent qu'est-ce que vous mettez
derrière cette expression de roman
national parce que vous expliquez
longuement que d'écrire la France ça n'a
rien à voir avec raconter la France
absolument c'est très important alors
l'expression roman nationale elle est
assez récente elle date de les années 90
sous la plume de l'historien Pierre Nora
et la définition communément admise
c'est de dire c'est la narration
romancée que se fait une nation
d'elle-même voilà et c'est intéressant
s'il y a deux dimensions il y a
dimension
apprécie unificateur et une dimension
d'imaginaire c'est vrai que c'est
contempteurs vont dire attention c'est
pas la réalité c'est une version
réécrite de l'histoire ou la nation et
au contraire ces défenseurs vont dire
oui mais peut-être mais en tout cas ça
unit ça tient ensemble une société mais
là le point essentiel c'est de dire on
croule sous les descriptions de la
société française les librairies ne sont
pleins les émissions sont plein les
géographes et économistes les
politologues bon ce qui manque
cruellement et c'est ce qui m'ont c'est
ce que mon parfaitement le résultat du
son agifop personne ne le raconte ce
pays c'est à dire propose un récit
enthousiasmant puissant articuler
capable d'assembler des morceaux de réel
totalement éparpillés et qui est capable
de répondre à des questions très simples
mais vertigineuses qu'est-ce qui nous
tient encore ensemble aujourd'hui et
vers quel horizon commun on se décide
est-ce qu'on est vraiment cette archipel
français condamné avoir ces différents
îlots s'éloigner inexorablement les uns
des autres ou est-ce qu'on a encore
encore une fois des choses qui nous
relient alors justement en travers la
nation pour rester sur la question du
vide cette défaillance narrative des
politiques est-ce que vous pouvez la
dater et l'expliquer depuis quand et
pourquoi
alors la date et c'est compliqué
je pense qu'il y a un moment que le
capitalisme notamment numérique est en
tournant ça c'est sûr tout il faut pas
charger totalement la barre sur le
politique il y a d'abord l'émergence
d'un capitalisme de l'écran et numérique
qui rend plus difficile l'existence même
d'un récitationnel quand on a un acteur
comme Netflix par exemple qui clusterise
ces populations on est plus du tout sur
l'air TF1 on regardait tous la même
chose non Netflix nous nous sectionne
nos segmente au plus près ils divisent
leur 230 millions d'abonnés en 2000
communautés de goût mais voilà que ça
rend beaucoup plus difficile le fait
d'avoir des consommations partagées qui
étaient autrefois le ciment d'une vision
du monde partagé bon là où c'est
intéressant comme pour mettre le point
ce politique parce que ce livre c'est
d'abord et avant tout une intervention
au politique mais est-ce que c'est parce
que le monde est devenu trop chaotique
et trop illisible que les politiques
n'arrivent plus à le à le raconter parce
que au fond on passe de crises en crise
et qu'ils sont démunis ils font du
storytelling ce qui n'a rien à voir avec
le roman national alors l'une des tests
que je défends c'est que le rôle du
politique c'est pas juste de gagner des
élections et c'est pas juste de mettre
en place des politiques publiques le
rôle du politique ça ne fonction
symbolique c'est de rendre lisiblement
dans lequel on est et précisément c'est
d'autant plus aujourd'hui le cas que le
monde est d'autant plus compliqué que ça
le rend d'autant plus nécessaire
aujourd'hui bon la thèse il me semble
pas à votre question sur pourquoi il y a
une confusion généralisée au sein de la
classe politique entre narration et
communication c'est-à-dire ce rôle de
compteur national que j'ai essayé de
décrire en quelques mots et aujourd'hui
mis derrière des stratégies de
communication c'est des stratégies
d'image beaucoup plus personnelle où on
va raconter une trajectoire on va
raconter des rapports de force politique
mais on perdant totalement de vue c'est
cette dimension très noble alors quel
est le fait de raconter la France à
l'extrême droite qui s'est essayé à se
récit national c'était Éric Zemmour
pendant la campagne présidentielle tout
le monde se souvient de son clip de de
campagne il a tourné aux fiasco parce
qu'il avait emprunté toute une série de
films du patrimoine mais là on le voit
il tente de restituer cette fameuse
scène de la BBC du général de Gaulle
l'appel du 18 juin 40 et ça sonne faux
complètement faux je suis pas sûr non à
titre personnel je peux le penser mais à
l'époque ça a suitait énormément
d'enthousiasme à droite et à l'extrême
droite pourquoi parce que voilà
quelqu'un qui fait une OPA sur
l'imaginaire national parce qu'il vient
se réapproprier tout ce qui fait
l'essence même de l'esprit français de
manière totalement scandaleuse parce
qu'il va se réapproprier non seulement
les codes de la chevalerie Molière
Racine les films de Claude sauter les
chansons de Brassens et de Barbara non
mais c'était extrêmement bien articulé
et vous avez raison de souligner
un peu accumulation en tout cas il y
avait une volonté justement de toucher
de volonté de toucher ce qui constitue
l'âme et l'esprit français bon il le
fait de manière totalement dans la
récupération parce que comment est-ce
que un candidat d'extrême droite peut
récupérer les chansons de Barbara on se
pose encore la question en revanche il
me semble que une partie de la panique
qu'il a suscité à l'automne 2021 on se
rappelle il est qualifié au deuxième
tour donner à 18% dans un sondage de
novembre 21 nous n'oublions pas ça c'est
que nous n'ayons pas ce regard
rétrospectif au regard des résultats
qu'il a eu après coup je pense qu'une
partie de la panique venait du fait que
on s'est rendu compte qu'en face le
récit national a opposé à celui proposé
par examen était totalement inexistant
et encore une fois ce vide il est non
seulement instrumentalisé depuis
toujours par l'extrême droite
identitaire qui s'est parfaitement
s'approprier les codes nationaux pour
raconter la France là le phénomène sur
lequel je mets le doigt c'est qu'il y a
d'autres types d'acteurs qui sont pas
des acteurs d'extrême droite qui sont
les acteurs non démocratiques des
acteurs marchands sont les marques
commerciales qui exploitent ce vide
justement c'est très intéressant
d'ailleurs cette idée de un peu de faire
nation par la consommation c'est
McDonald's vous raconter ça très bien
qui est la première marque parce que ça
nous vient des États-Unis tout ça à
avoir raconté la France en s'adaptant à
à notre pays en particulier alors que
c'est une multinationale présente dans
le monde entier en deux mots
effectivement c'est important de dire
que ça vient des États-Unis il y a un
historien américain qui s'appelle
boursed qui a raconté que post guerre
civile pour faire des Américains des
citoyens qui s'étaient bagarrés entre
eux l'identité américaine par la
consommation a fait ciment c'est à dire
que des citoyens américains qui
s'étaient profondément divisés vont
refaire nation par la consommation
de bagnoles de clopes etc bon en France
je me suis posé la question mais au fond
depuis quand est-ce que démarre
racontent la France depuis toujours la
France est en arrière fond de beaucoup
de spots publicitaires on se rappelle
des campagnes de Jacques Séguela dans
les années 80 quand il veut vendre sa
Citroën Visa GTI il le fait sur le porte
porte-avion le Clémenceau les packagings
des camemberts présidents on voit une
image d'Épinal d'un village français bon
le fait nouveau c'est que des marques
vont parler explicitement de la France
c'est-à-dire que la France passe du
décor au du sujet devient le discours
principal et précisément ça ça change la
donne voilà et c'est un peu ça que j'ai
voulu raconter c'est que on a des
acteurs qui portent une vision explicite
de la société française et ça c'est très
important ce que nous divise ce qui ce
qui nous point même parfois d'entrer de
plein pied dans le débat public sur des
sujets particulièrement polémiques quand
une publicité ce politique regardez
c'est un extrait de la pub Sephora
moi c'est Khadija j'ai 26 ans
actuellement je suis conseiller
clientèle je suis d'origine malienne
j'ai commencé le foot parce que j'aimais
bien me donner j'aime bien être dans une
équipe ça rassemble énormément donc
j'ai pas vraiment fait de foot en club
parce que je me sentais pas forcément à
ma place et vraiment la première équipe
à laquelle j'ai fait partie c'est les
jalouses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça génère énormément de réactions
notamment à droite et à l'extrême droite
on a on avait clairement un récit
politique celui de la droite et un récit
d'une marque qui s'opposait dans le
débat ça c'est très nouveau bah c'est
très nouveau c'est que à quoi on a
affaire on a affaire à une marque du
groupe LVMH qui est l'enseigne de beauté
préférée des plus jeunes des 18-35 ans
et qui se met explicitement apporté une
vision de la société qui est loin d'être
consensuelle c'est ce qu'on apprend
traditionnellement dans les écoles de
commerce c'est surtout ne faites pas de
politique on veut fourguer des produits
au plus grand nombre de personnes bon là
il y a explicitement la proposition
d'une vision de la société avec
effectivement c'est hidgets qu'est-ce
que ça fait c'est le deuxième
enseignement ça devient un sujet débat
politique ça aurait pu être circonscrit
à la zone commerciale les politiques ça
n'en parle les politiques s'en emparent
pour les défendre je pense à Aurélien
tacher qui a pris position pour
applaudir des deux mains ou au contraire
pour les instrumentaliser deux erikiotti
Erik Zemmour on en parle tout à l'heure
Eric Zemmour qu'est-ce qu'il prend il
prend cet exemple de la publicité pour
dire je cite ses publicités existent
parce que la clientèle de Sephora c'est
grand remplacé ça c'est intéressant ça
voilà des voilà des partis politiques
qui prennent appui sur des objets de
consommation populaire pour pouvoir
mener leur propre bataille dernière
question on sort de plusieurs polémiques
il y a eu celle de la cérémonie du
d'ouverture du Mondial de rugby avec
voilà Béré casquette bereklop ou non
béret baguette plutôt et puis cette
fameuse polémique absolument de Juliette
Armanet qui avait critiqué Connemara la
fameuse chanson de Michel Sardou elle
dit quoi ses polémique vous dites que on
est dans on s'élarchipelisation ça on
est dans des fractures culturelles on ne
se parle plus avec au fond une guerre
culturelle si forte vous vous parlez
d'une société en playlist ça veut dire
quoi
alors moi j'essaye de de bâtir de battre
un peu en brèche cette vision de
l'archipel parce que je pense que cette
vision là nous pousse au fond à ne plus
avoir quoi que ce soit en commun et
cette métaphore n'est pas juste
descriptive elle devient agissante il
faut faire très attention à ce que cette
métaphore de l'archipel ne devienne pas
une forme de fatalisme ou nous serions
condamnés à ne plus avoir rien à faire
les uns avec les autres cette métaphore
de la société en playlist elle est
parfaitement adaptée au sujet Juliette
Armani parce que dans ma playlist
personnelle j'ai et les lacs du
Connemara mais ils sont de Michel Sardou
des années 80 et le premier jour du
disco le 18e
c'est à dire que je crois qu'on est dans
une société qui précisément a totalement
étendu et fait éclater les zones de
contact culturel et idéologique par la
musique la gastronomie les séries on est
habitué donc il y a des ponts entre les
archipels exactement et au fond on peut
avoir l'adjonction non parano et non
conflictuelle de plein de différences et
d'objets de consommation qui qui ne
rentrent pas nécessairement
d'espérer quelque part pour faire du
commun et que ce soit les politiques qui
reprennent ce rôle le roman national des
marques vous l'aurez compris c'est
extrêmement stimulant c'est un récit
très original c'est très fouillé il y a
énormément de références et j'en profite
pour remercier aussi la maison de la
publicité qui nous a permis de diffuser
tous ces spots vous restez avec moi
Raphaël yorka c'est l'heure d'accueillir
nos affranchis leur parti pris vont vous
faire réagir on les accueille tout de
suite
et maître Perrier du vendredi qu'on est
ravis de retrouver bonsoir Bertrand
bienvenue Nathan de verre également
qu'on est ravi de vous retrouver cette
nouvelle saison va commencer par action
ou planètes la nouvelle chronique écolo
de Léa Falco bonsoir Léa vous vouliez
nous parler d'infrastructure autoroute
la 69 par exemple entre Toulouse et
Castres c'est un vieux dossier un vieux
serpent de mer de la région et vous
vouliez aller un peu plus loin
c'est-à-dire parce que plus que de
parler de cette autoroute il faut aussi
se demander je pense pourquoi est-ce
qu'en 2023 on continue à investir dans
des projets qui paraissent anachroniques
et en plus par investir qu'un peu mais
investir des centaines de millions
d'euros d'argent public alors pour
comprendre pourquoi il faut regarder un
peu à l'intérieur du mécanisme de
financement et surtout d'approbation de
ces grands projets quand on crée une
infrastructure forcément il faut faire
un arbitrage entre des avantages et des
inconvénients pour faire ça et pour
pouvoir objectiver un petit peu tout un
tas de réalités différentes on fait ce
qu'on appelle une analyse socio
économique l'idée qui a derrière c'est
de pouvoir transformer en euros des
enjeux qui sont très différents sociaux
environnementaux financiers économiques
évidemment et donc infinés vous vous
retrouvez avec quelque chose qui est
censé pouvoir orienter ou au moins aider
la décision en montrant de manière
claire et objectivée les avantages et
les inconvénients sauf que déjà c'est
compliqué évidemment de discréter
combien d'euros vaut un arbre ou la
tranquillité d'esprit ou le fait de
pouvoir aller au travail des riverains
en plus les projets d'infrastructures
forcément ça s'étend en général sur des
années voire des décennies et donc entre
le moment où le travail est acté et
celui où il commence vraiment ses
valeurs et le les valeurs monétaires qui
sont associées elles ont le temps
d'évoluer et dans le cas de la 69
l'analyse socio-économique la première
elle date de plus de 20 ans et donc elle
n'est peut-être pas encore tout à fait
adapté aux enjeux qu'on a aujourd'hui
l'autorité environnementale qui en a
fait un rapport début 2022 notait
qu'elle n'avait pas été actualisée et
que de fait elle reposait sur des
hypothèses qui étaient pour bonne partie
obsolète alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
abandonne le projet et bah c'est une
possibilité on pourrait imaginer qu'il
puisse se produire un moratoire sur ses
grands projets d'infrastructure et qu'on
les réévalue avec une grille de lecture
qui serait plus adaptée aux enjeux du
21e siècle et puis en plus il y a
certains projets qu'on pourrait
réorienter pour retourner sur l'exemple
de la 69 le alors pour rappeler un petit
peu ce que c'est c'est donc une
autoroute qui est construite à côté
d'une nationale qui existe déjà cette
autoroute écouterait environ 17 euros
aller-retour puisque géré par un privé
et procurer un gain de temps de trajet
entre 15 et 35 minutes selon les
analyses que vous regardez pour montrer
que autre chose est possible et qu'on
peut relier le Tarn au métropole qui
l'accompagne géographiquement d'une
autre manière le collectif La voix est
Libre a présenté ces derniers jours à
l'Assemblée nationale une version
alternative c'est à dire un projet qui
consisterait à créer une vélo route à
réhabiliter la nation qui existe déjà et
à réaménager le réseau de transport en
commun pour qu'il desservent ces
villages là donc c'est possible et en
plus le projet qu'il propose coûterait
100 millions d'euros d'argent public
contre les 450 millions qui sont
actuellement à louer au projet de
l'autoroute a69 mais derrière tout ça
derrière le cas qui est devenu un peu
symbolique de la 69 il y a non seulement
beaucoup de projets d'autoroute qu'on
pourrait juger discutables de la 154 à
la 813 mais en plus il y a cette vraie
question fondamentale comment est-ce que
aujourd'hui en 2023 on change les
grilles d'analyse de nos projets
d'infrastructures pour décider dans quoi
on investit ou pas j'ai l'impression
qu'on n'est pas encore au changement de
logiciel en matière d'infrastructure en
tout cas merci je sais pas comment vous
faites sans note vos chroniques je suis
bluffée j'en profite évidemment bien
voilà merci Léa Nathan Nathan de verre
vous lire revenir sur le déplacement
d'Emmanuel Macron en Corse hier et ce
mot d'autonomie qu'il a même quasiment
promis à territoriale de Corse oui
exactement Emmanuel Macron c'est rendu
encore dans un contexte où depuis un
certain nombre de mois ce mot
d'autonomie revient déjà beaucoup dans
le débat public interne à la Corse avec
des à la fois des
indépendantistes et en même temps des
autonomies qui prennent de plus en plus
si vous voulez de d'importance dans le
débat notamment depuis la mort d'Yvan
Colonna en mars 2022 et il y avait eu
aussi en juillet dernier l'Assemblée de
Corse qui avait voté quasiment à
l'unanimité une délibération qui
recensait toutes les revendications de
la cause Corse parmi lesquels la
reconnaissance officielle du peuple
corse et pas de la communauté vraiment
du peuple corse la co-officialité de la
langue par rapport à la langue française
le statut de résident et puis des
protections aussi sur le foncier pour
éviter que ce soit livré à des
spéculations qui rendent la Corse
inhabitable
a montré que si vous voulez dans son
discours qu'il avait entendu ce
changement si vous voulez de
revendications et il a quand même montré
que il approuvait cette tendance globale
donc il a prononcé d'abord le mot
d'autonomie et il la prononcé sans le
faire du bout des lèvres sans mettre des
nuances sans mettre des réticences et ça
d'abord c'est un geste politique fort
rien que d'avoir fait cela ensuite il a
évoqué selon lui la nécessité ou
l'éventualité d'inscrire dans la
Constitution la reconnaissance un
article entier reconnaissant l'accord
comme une communauté non pas comme un
peuple mais communauté historique
linguistique et culturel et puis une
reconnaissance du bilinguisme donc là
vous voyez c'est on n'est pas tout à
fait dans les revendications mais en
tout cas on s'en rapproche alors
évidemment ce discours là même s'il a
été perçu comme un acte politique
important sa réalisabilité posera
problème parce que réviser la
Constitution difficile et on sait qu'en
2018 ça n'avait pas été possible
absolument c'est un peu une volte-face
pour le Président il est arrivé une
première fois très jacobin il voulait
pas entendre parler du tout de
d'autonomie ou de révolution
constitutionnelle et il revient
là-dessus comme on voulait expliquer ça
c'est une volte-face et il me semble que
cette volte-face il y a deux analyses
possibles qu'on peut en faire et un peu
dans la logique de refuser une une
archipelisation des esprits je ne
trancherai pas nécessairement entre les
deux mais la première est de dire que
c'est notamment celle de Benjamin Morel
qui a écrit une tribune assez ferme
là-dessus c'est de dire que ça va dans
le sens d'une dislocation du territoire
national avec tous les risques que ça
engendre c'est qu'on puisse avoir des
régions d'autres collectivités qui
puissent revendiquer aussi comme ça des
des choses plus d'autonomie dans leur
sens c'est que ça puisse aussi créer une
situation où l'exécutif peut jouer sur
les différences territoriales en
fonction des affinités avec des élus
locaux et ça ça peut avoir un risque
politique et la troisième c'est qu'on
est à mi-chemin parfois de la
revendication
identitaire mais en face moi ça m'a
quand même rappeler le fait que Rousseau
qui est le grand penseur du contrôle du
contrat social dont il explique que ce
contrat social se réalise très
difficilement dans une nation disait que
selon lui le lieu de la démocratie c'est
des petits territoires et parmi lesquels
chapitre 10 du entre deux du contrat
social il dit il est encore en Europe un
pays capable de législation c'est l'île
de Corse etc etc j'ai quelques
pressentiments qu'un jour cette petite
île étonnera l'Europe très monitoire
Jacques Rousseau on enchaîne pour vous
laisser quand même encore un petit peu
de temps parce que voilà ça hurle je
suis Joseph dire Bertrand vous voulez
revenir sur l'élection hier de
l'écrivain Franco libanais amine malouf
au poste de Secrétaire perpétuel s'il
vous plaît de l'Académie française et
oui et donc amine malouf qui était déjà
immortel est devenu en plus perpétuelle
c'est assez amusant d'ailleurs c'est un
poste à vie donc pour un immortel c'est
un peu paradoxal et l'autre ironie de
l'histoire c'est que quand en 2011 il a
été élu à l'Académie française et bien
il a été reçu sur la coupole sous la
coupole par Jean-Christophe Rufin qui
est précisément celui qui l'a affronté à
l'élection d'hier de secrétaire
perpétuel qui a donc battu par 24 voix
contre 8 pour succéder à Hélène carrière
d'encause décédé cet été racontez-nous
très très amical en fait pas du tout les
couteaux sont sortis il y a des
intrigues on se croirait dans la Rome
antique des conjurations des
conspirations des boules puantes c'est
vraiment des des gens incroyables les
académiciens parce qu'ils ont
globalement une intelligence absolument
supérieure et un peu de temps et donc
tout ça fait que selon des trucs
absolument invraisemblables et
l'élection de amine malouf on a été le
signe ça faisait un petit moment que
Jean-Christophe Rufin avait envisagé de
se présenter il l'avait un peu annoncé
avant l'été et alors là il y a une
campagne de dénigrement il a dit non pas
du tout je n'irai jamais contre mon ami
ma louve et puis il finit il a dit non
mais ça va faire une élection à un seul
candidat c'est nord-coréens ça ne va pas
et en toute limite lundi il a dit je me
présente et donc bah voilà ça fait moins
cher Malou c'est un bon choix pour vous
ah oui c'est évidemment un bon choix
c'est un bon choix parce que c'est un
grand écrivain ça marquant de Léon
l'Africain c'est un bon choix connu et
donc l'Académie a aussi besoin de cette
notoriété là c'est un ancien journaliste
et puis il est très investi il aime
beaucoup l'Académie et puis la dernière
raison est quand même c'est que aminalo
c'est le Liban c'est aussi la
francophonie incarnée et c'est important
pour un pays qui est aussi meurtri de
lui donner ce signe d'affection
française et c'est un polyglotte qui
défend la langue française mais c'est un
homme et vous vouliez je conclure là
dessus encore un homme c'est un homme
alors de toute façon il ne pouvait pas
enfin être trop trop parce que il y a
quand même que à l'Académie six femmes
pour 29 hommes mais il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant sur lequel avait une
malouf aura responsive très vite il y a
cinq fauteuils vacants à l'Académie il y
a cinq places libres donc peut-être vous
pourriez être candidate
pour que enfin le mot immortalité soit
un mot féminin merci beaucoup et pardon
pour vous avoir autant pressé merci les
affranchis vous l'entendez c'est terminé
c'est le week-end profitez bien pour
lire le roman national des marques aux
éditions la Fondation Jean Jaurès et
l'édition de l'Aube Merci à VOUS Raphaël
Lorca à très vite et très belle soirée
bien sûr
[Musique]